all right another episode of hey babe
coming up right now this episode we talk
about a documentary that will blow your
balls off
it's basically about a guy who's
standing on the ocean floor and gets
untethered from his safety line boat
dude as a tank with 15 minutes of oxygen
in them yeah you are your balls where
are your balls they're not they're not
in my pants 100 percent blown off they
blew through the walls during that
conversation bubs and it's a great
episode we'll talk about your abilities
of dancing your whole life of dancing we
talk about
why you're afraid to dance how you dance
where you can dance why you can't dance
through christie's life you gotta
approach by dancing with the stars this
is all on the next step
and where do you leave it all off too
you talk about the crazy pool day with
the kids oh my the crazy that's where i
leave it all is in the pool of my kids
we'll talk all about that we also talk
about the merch that we have i mean look
at these t-shirts this is my favorite
t-shirt i've ever seen of any podcast
ever you can get that at
salvocanocomedy.com or chrisdcomedy.com
and there's this uh hey babe hoodie
there's more of this logo this is the
gold on black and then of course you got
the 119 the hey babe here and kane
tanaka versus everybody baby all that
much is out my comedy special is
streaming on netflix called special
weshy july 8th and 9th providence august
17th to the 20th brea improv september
30th chicago theater chrisdcomedy.com
how about this one tonight which is june
16th tonight thursday night is the
premiere of the last episode the last
eight episodes of season nine of jokers
all new and practical jokers on tonight
isn't that crazy and then uh tomorrow uh
the 17th in two days i'm in milwaukee at
the pabst uh then the 18th i'm in
minneapolis at the is it pantages
pantages yeah
24th of june i'm in the hampton beach
casino and then july is a big one in
july we got vegas phoenix and colorado
portland seattle and vancouver
don't run away from your feelings babe
don't be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey babe hey babe hey
i just met baby
and this is crazy
but here's my number
so call me hey babe hey babe what's
going on do you know call me maybe by
carly rae jepsen was the first song that
was engineered completely 100
in a lab they
scientists made that song with the
different notes and inflections and um
music tones to basically match
to release more dopamine inside a human
brain they took scientifically what type
of songs make people happy and they made
that in a lab and it uncovered a formula
what the [ __ ] are you talking about
maybe right here with your heart up top
baby but wait
what do you what do you even mean how do
you know that where did you hear that
what are we talking about so she's so
she's not even she's getting the credit
for it though she might she might even
be a bot
she you're telling me this oh wait oh
you you just read that from there no no
i knew that and then
pulled it up said scientists working in
a top secret canadian laboratory
uncovered a formula to maximize the
addictive qualities of a pop song in
september the formula was leaked by way
of a song called call me maybe and
performed by a 26 year old canadian idol
winner named carly ray has a hard time
believing that's real and many people
have duplicated this scientists in a top
secret canadian laboratory they said
they figured out what makes all
generations happy from little kids to
grant to grandparents and that's why and
they use that same form you know what
you know what formula they use to make
you know what you know what song was
made by this formula what wet ass [ __ ]
no way swear to god
well i mean they're two big hits
hey you know what actually i'm kidding
but it could be true yeah um yeah dude
so when yeah you see when you listen to
tunes that move you your brain releases
dopamine a chemical involved in both
motivation
but that so that's what they did and you
know dancing you know what dancing is
like from a scientific point of view
your brain is getting so over stimulated
that your body doesn't know what to do
so it just starts moving in rhythmic
patterns is that really what the brain
literally is losing it's [ __ ] right
because and it's like i don't know what
to do i'm so excited
that it moves wow isn't that wild
that's [ __ ] nuts yeah well what about
like like you don't you do you don't
really dance right
let's talk to me like
what's what do you think your skill
level is
10 being you're on so you think you can
dance and zero being you're in a
wheelchair
it's interesting you say that the last
part no cuz it's offense it's just that
it's no sense a lot of times people in a
wheelchair they're there they have a
broken leg or something like that they
can't get up
like anything you know yeah ominous
shadow wheelchairs baby shout out
wheelchairs i love her i gotta tell you
story about a wheelchair let me ask you
this if you're in a wheelchair and you
get the death penalty do you just hook
the electricity up to the wheelchair
would you move them out and then put
them in the election these are things i
i think about every night
it's something i've never thought about
one of those two um so i would say
dancing
when your body when your brain's going
nuts and can't handle anymore what does
your body do
what my body does is it is it sits right
down
in a chair because as far as chair if
you want to say dancing seated i'm one
of the best to ever do it right i can
chair
yeah ready hey i just met you
and this is crazy
but here's my number
so call me hey babe
wow you like that you had like a little
flare at the end too so you have
confidence seated
seated about confidence or just just the
lower half of your body doesn't have
the dopamine doesn't get to it
yeah i i don't think the dopamine can
travel to my legs
for some reason because my legs
literally never work when when i'm
dancing but the upper part of my body i
can move all day every day
it's very strange so
when when you were a young kid and you
were at a at a disco tech or something
right and and then a girl would take you
onto the dance floor what would you end
up doing did you just let them dance
around you dance around me or i tried to
just move in a very very very small
square grid right just try to move that
but dancing i would always ask if a girl
wanted to like you know be like come on
sit on my lap baby you know uh and then
i would dance with her like that because
i just genuinely i genuinely
i get i think that i could dance
but i get so worked up mentally
i freeze up do you not feel confident to
dance i don't feel confident and is it
because you don't know what to
you
can't move your body in a way that you
feel would rhythmically match what's
going on
i think it's because when i was a kid
somebody said that i danced like stephen
hawking okay and that bothered me okay i
can see how it would yeah because he
doesn't really dance you know like
yeah because he didn't he could only
control his eyes right right
is that what you do
yeah so i think that i think that
i can slow dance i try i'm very aware of
not stepping on a foot um but i can't
dance but i i'll say this okay i think
it's
less of a problem that a guy can't dance
and more of a problem when a woman can't
dance yeah i think if a woman can't
dance that's a bigger issue because
they're expected to know how to dance
it's true i i don't i don't i rarely see
a woman that's like oh i don't dance i
rarely see it and i rarely see a woman
on a dance floor that doesn't really
dance
well enough i'll tell you this
god's honest truth
latina women my 11 month old latina
daughter has can't walk yeah can dance
better than me i've seen it she can
dance better than me i've seen it in my
latino nieces they're better than us
they're just like they already have a
built-in thing now i will say i not i
don't do it much now but i am half a
latino and thus i've been dancing my
whole life now there are times where i
have to get on the dance floor and leave
it all out there you have to i have to
and i do i leave it all
you're not going to leave it all out
there what do you need
fifty percent of the time i'm out there
i leave it there hundred percent
hundred percent at fifty percent it's
left you have to go back and get it you
forgot it yeah the other 50 i still
contribute but i maybe not don't leave
it all out there
in your body and your heart your soul
and your mind when you're hearing
something and your brain's going nuts
and you wish you could leave it all out
there
and you don't what happens how does that
make you feel because you can't just
walk around your whole life not leaving
it out there
i feel like a failure
i feel i think i do get depressed when i
don't leave it all out there when i'm at
a dance floor when i'm when i'm at a a
place where there's music and i'm not
dancing i'm not contributing like i went
to a concert i love the 1975. i went to
the 1975 concert in november of 2019 at
the bb t center in camden new jersey
yeah and i locked your doors well i
locked my doors i sat in my seat the
entire time i might have been the only
person out of those 10 000 plus people
that didn't get up because i was too
scared to dance to the songs that i know
and love where in my car driving to the
concert
dancing like
yeah literally i was dancing like i'm
like i'm a colombian woman right right
yeah so what can't why can't you did you
ever try did you ever say this is going
to be my moment
make me or break me i'm going to go out
there i'm going to leave it out there
well you know what happened is too one
time when i was like in my early 20s and
one i was out with my friend his
girlfriend some of his girlfriend's
friends and like the guy you know was
like oh you don't dance and i was like
no i dance and then he was like let me
see you dance and then i tried to start
to dance and then they started making
fun of me bad like because i couldn't
dance at all and then and then everyone
was trying to help me learn how to dance
and that was like demoralizing
embarrassing whatever so then i remember
that was the same night that we were at
this place called patty mcgee's in long
beach that was the same night that my
friend
was dancing with a woman on the dance
floor but she was born a
biological male this is way before those
terms even existed this was
15 years ago and the panama giza was by
the water biological male existed but
biological male existed but like the
terms but he basically like was kissing
her neck and noticed she he had an
adam's apple and he didn't like that he
wasn't told that she was born a guy so
they got into like a fist fight and the
guy
the the
biological male who turned female
punched my friend in the face and
knocked him over railing and he fell
into the long island sound or whatever
that is water by patty mcgee's and
that's that that moment my my friend
getting knocked unconscious by a
transgender person into water saved me
the embarrassment of all these people
looking at me while i was dancing wow so
that er the whole transgender community
has been a champion of you for 15 years
i've literally been saved by trans
people since 2003. that's unbelievable
they've been saving me every year wow
they saved they've saved my career in
the last two
[Laughter]
so all right so i wonder what a lifetime
of because if you don't leave it out
there you take it back with you so you
go home and you always take it back with
you home you're not leaving it anyway
you know what's something i noticed too
and shout out my mom my mom's a great
person but shout out my mom and if
you're watching and we know we know you
are
she a lot of times when i carry this
with me and i'm trying to be very
conscious not do this to my daughters
because it was an accident but this is
what happens we can only as generations
go on we can only you know try to be a
little bit better for the next gen
my mother would always you know when i
was a kid eight nine ten years old she'd
come in you know like say i'd be sitting
in a living or whatever she'd come in
with an outfit on that she was gonna
wear to work the next day she's like
does this make me look fat
and i'd say no it doesn't like you know
you look great she's like i feel so fat
in this and then she would like take her
like um you know like i'd hear her like
taking the blouse off whatever and
slamming it and be like you're so fat
like that and then i started to think
like that then i started to have body
shaming issues because and i was skinny
or in shape but i i took that with me
always and i didn't start realizing
until i had my daughter so i was like oh
don't do that even if you feel like a
fat piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah do not do
that in front of your kids because then
she
tells you she had no idea that i was i
was absorbing that right so then because
i was absorbing that then i start to
come with body dysmorphia issues or
whatever so i want to make sure if slam
your blouse slam my blouse so that's why
i'm all my daughters i'm all i'm talking
about the good wolf and the bad wolf i'm
saying baby you feed that good wolf yeah
you got the bad wolf inside you even if
that don't let the bad wolf eat that
blouse it's just about the good wolf let
the bedroom
so i think that's what happened with
dancing with me was i was like you know
everybody was making fun of my dancing
and everyone's saying i was a bad dancer
even though inside i did feel like well
wait bring out a chair and i'll bust
your ass and he's right
literally make me paraplegic put me in a
wheelchair for life i'll win every dance
competition in the world that's that's
extreme but i'm willing to go there yeah
um
you you know so then i've carried it
with me so now i'm 37 maybe 38 by the
time this episode comes out um oh well
august 26th no i'll still be clearly 30
so yeah yeah um
but i'll be i'm at the end of the 37th
here yeah so of life so i i um um
i i now don't dance at all it's not
something that i ever want to do i don't
now i'm past peer pressure so now i'm
like i don't care if i ever learn how to
dance i don't want to learn how to i
don't care you don't have to desire when
your song comes on to just kick your
heels off and run as a matter of fact i
didn't tell you this but it's weird
we're talking about this and i said no i
politely declined do you know
last week i got asked if i would be
willing to consider to be in dancing
with the stars wow
i got asked i was i was in consideration
if i they wanted to go that route
because a netflix special and i said no
and my agent was like are you sure it's
like a big competition thing like it you
can be the comedy guy you could be the
funny guy it would be good for your
career i said i'm not in a million years
i am not i'd rather do stand-up comedy
butt naked like literally but fully butt
naked on national television then go on
dancing with the stars fully closed
because you be you feel like there's no
way you can pull it off you'd be
humiliating i don't i'm just at a point
in my life there's a lot of things i do
want to change there's a lot of things
i'm very willing to open myself up to
get embarrassed for like
you know comedy or or like learning a
new thing or being called stupid because
i don't know this or that dancing i just
have it in i don't care if i ever learn
it i don't want to learn it i don't want
anything to do with it as a matter of
fact when there's music i might put on
sound cancelling headphones in public
i just i'm so excited you know what
amount of money i would pay
to see you on live national television
doing a pasa doble
do you understand how much money i would
pay do i'm going to call and dance with
the stars people and say i'm back in sal
is going to give me 10 mil
listen to me right now honestly we
should work something out we should
start a gofundme for you okay just look
you'll be eliminated in week one we know
this 100 but could you imagine i made it
to week two you the person who i've
beaten dancing with the stars would have
to be the worst dancer of all time well
they've had people on like that can't
even move at all so i would say honestly
with your fan base because i don't know
if they still vote like by tell like
vote for you by telephone or something
like that yeah or text but like uh i
think that you would maybe make it to we
two or three but again a pasta doughble
if we could what's a pasta dough oh babe
a pasta dough blender we know what a
pasta dough play is yeah it's a very uh
it's like that bull riding like uh oh
okay you know like that that kind of
spanish very uh
it's it's a very uh
i don't know what it is but you know i
don't know how to describe it a pasta
is not a word yeah possible there it is
there we go
apostle david
so this is latin ballroom dancing yeah
yeah yeah but it's very like uh like uh
you you have to hold your your your
chest up your gait like you have to be
very proper and stiff you want to lose
weight and get in shape you start
dancing oh tell me about it 100 you
start dancing yeah you cannot be fat and
be dance at this level
they practice six to eight hours a day
six to eight hours a day yeah six to
eight hours a day now
this isn't even one like you gotta you
gotta see like a a real pasta double
that's like like very uh
fiery that's what it is there's a fire
in the pasta you know what i might do i
might learn a pasta doughbly and tell no
one come out a year from now and just
invite you guys to a show at the end
come out i'll pass a doble all over you
yeah
do you know i mean honestly like that's
what that's what it's like got it and
you get to wear those outfits that's the
outfit babe do are we do we need to
dress like this on the next day baby
yeah
do we need to get a pasta don't play
alcohol room outfits just full and never
address it never just sit down yeah look
at that can you imagine you i know
though look at that you know how you
know how scary that is to be in front of
on national television live
in that arena there with like a couple
of like a thousand people looking at
what would you rather do would you
rather be on dancing with the stars
doing a possible play or doing comedy
butt naked probably calm but
complimentary i would do that i got it i
got i got approached a bit back on this
you dancing with the stuff yeah and you
said no i it wasn't a fish and i i
thought about it because i have a but
you know what this is totally different
just because you could dance a little
bit on a dance floor doesn't mean you
could do a pass now listen you hear
people that do it that they love it you
know you know they had fun but they have
some background in dancing or they just
want to learn it i think i'm just not
motivated yeah at all to learn yeah i
just i i don't
i think that's a good thing about
getting older some sometimes is like
where it's like there's certain things
that i definitely need to improve yeah
100 and i'm willing to try to work on
those i haven't necessarily put a plan
forward yet but i i know that i want to
do that sure certain things where i
don't care at all
i just have given up ever caring if i
learned that know that that's what
that's what happens it's like i don't
care it's a breath of fresh air when you
get older yeah i just like i don't give
a [ __ ] anymore i'm good with that
whatever like
where do you leave it all out there
if not dancing
on a comedy stage probably oh outside
outside of comedy on the comedy stage
not necessarily where where where do you
leave it all out i would say where i
really leave it out there no where i've
where i've just recently learned well i
am leaving it out there leave it there
in the pool with my kids yeah i did not
realize it's the first summer we've had
a pool
yes my daughter was like dad yeah i
cannot believe how crazy you are
fully
taking my seven-year-old
trying to launch her yeah from on the
concrete from the shallow end to the
pool to the deep end of the pool where
if i threw her just a little bit further
she would have hit the concrete on the
outside of the ball jasmine came outside
and was like
stop
throwing our daughter and you were like
i'm leaving it out i'm like genuinely
look at how look at her smile yeah like
she is having the most fun of all time i
was willing do you realize that christus
olay memorial day weekend i wanted to i
said i was trying to figure out if we
could do it i was willing to jump from
my second floor window into the pool to
make my kids laugh
you real that's what you're doing you're
leaving i'm leaving it all out
pool floats under we were doing uh under
uh underwater diving competitions with
the goggles i was going down no goggles
okay um
chicken playing chicken um um throwing
tt jerry in the pool on all the floats
swimming competitions you know letting
letting people drown me all that stuff
cannonballs oh my god where the kids are
just standing there getting crazy with
the cannon you packed a lifetime of pool
into a day i went i went to the
walgreens on memorial day weekend i went
to walgreens shout out walgreens i went
to the walgreens and i went to look for
a slide i was willing to take a slide
that was meant to be outdoors i was
going to try to position it and tie it
to the fence and make a make make a
waterfall they sell
you mean like a traditional slide yeah
like like a fisher price like slide yeah
and i was willing to get my 240 pound
body on that slide and probably break it
the first time
i wouldn't go to for a slide if i'm
thinking if i'm just off the dome maybe
i'd go to like a i was taking a little a
little boogie board that they have and i
was trying to throw it out jump on it
and surf on the pool that has no waves
right
any second i could have fallen down and
crashed my head on the concrete leaving
all out there
here's how you know i left her out there
with the kids my daughter we got in the
pool at a child a seven-year-old child
we get in the pool at noon 2 p.m she had
enough she's like i'm pooped she a child
had enough i outlasted a seven-year-old
she was like i've had enough debt i
can't do this i gotta go to sleep for
the night wake up tomorrow morning we'll
keep having fun right she couldn't
handle it wow you leave it all out there
in the pool with my kids i love that i
love that i will not leave my kids out
there in the world
can i tell you something that's been
happening to me out of nowhere what what
would you say south i had to ask you
what would you say america's number one
at
meal kits that's what i'd say too well a
meal kit a milk from
hellofresh is america's number one meal
kit hola fresca yeah hello fresh yeah
america's number one meal kit i
literally i've been using hello fresh
weekly since the day we started this
podcast i have boxes of hellofresh
coming to my house weekly yeah i love
the food i cook it i i it's so easy to
cook it's all pre-packaged my i cook it
with the kids i can take a load off
jasmine's plate because i know how to do
this stuff the food is fantastic they
got these i had the um they had these
cucumber salad stuffed pita pockets for
summer
they were the best thing i've ever eaten
and they're healthy i know and you eat a
lot of stuff and you like a lot of stuff
and for that to make it i mean they have
chicken sausage stuffed with peppers
tuscan spice shrimp this is they changed
the menu a bunch you know yeah if you're
going away for the summer you could
update your delivery and enjoy hello
fresh at your vacation destination yes
and they got mediterranean recipes that
they got fresh fruits veggies nuts olive
oils fiber packed whole grains for
nourishing balance hello fresh literally
like whatever type of food you want they
got it 20-minute meals 30-minute meals
okay all the ingredients come in it's
cheaper than going to the store you
don't got to leave your house you can
pause any time you can switch what
you're getting in the mail anytime it's
a no-brainer uh go to hellofresh.com
slash hey babe 16 and use code hey babe
16 as in one six for up to 16 free meals
and three free gifts uh again that's
hellofresh.com hey babe uh 16 and use
code hey babe 16 for up to 16 free meals
and get three free gifts hello fresh
america's number one meal okay look
we're adults you and i are adults right
we're adults if you wanna you i know
where you're going with it if you wanna
use nicotine responsibly you want a
cleaner better alternative to nicotine
you got to try lucy you took the words
out of my mouth okay even though we're
in june it's a new year why not start it
out by it's a new half year why not
start it out by switching to a new
nicotine product that you can feel good
about i gave this nicotine product to
one of my aunts and she loves it she's
thanked me multiple times for it she's
been using the promo code babe at
lucy.co at checkout and she was getting
great discount but literally
this nicotine product lucy is she's told
me it's changed her life look for the
better if you enjoy using nicotine if
it's something you do check it out uh
check out lucy's products at lucy.co
they have the gum they have the pouches
they have the lozenges they have a bunch
of flavors
this product contains nicotine nicotine
is an addictive chemical 100 warning we
have to just give you that warning uh
and if you're interested in a better way
to use nicotino visit lucy.co
that's.go and be sure to use that promo
code babe babe
can i tell you something that's been
happening to me out of nowhere
twitch in my left eye three days ago too
much coffee too much caffeine i i
haven't been having caffeine
dry eyes allergies
okay time out okay three days ago i
started getting this twitch and it's
like
right and i'm like i feel it and i feel
it twitching i'm wondering if it's
visible and i was told stress i was told
stress could be but i'll tell you
another thing that happened starting
three days ago
seasonal allergies that i haven't had in
over a decade
seasonal allergies i've sneezed in the
last three days i've sneezed 30 times it
started three days ago the same time as
the eye twitch do you know what you're
talking about or something it's first of
all i'm i'm king of season allergies and
depression yeah as chrissy said
you have what you have i'm telling you
what you have you have eye your eyes are
dry either from over itching because of
the pollen getting in your eye or the
pollen actually dries out the eye what
you need is visine allergy drops can't
do it can't do it so what you need is
allergy drops okay you can't put any
drop in your eye never in my life has
that happened then it will never happen
you gotta start taking claritin then or
allegra
take the 24-hour one yeah because those
really give you nice works and you know
what i do sometimes i'm not supposed to
do this and i'm i don't know if i can
get in trouble by the fbi for admitting
this sometimes i take two 24 hours in a
24-hour span
that's give you double protection
does it give you double protection for
24 or extended protection for 48. i
think it gives you extended protection
for i think gives you double the
protection of 24. and your allergies all
day every year like i woke up this
morning
sneezing goo coming out of my eye nose
blowing my nose bleeding from my nose
full allergies i take the claritin
medicine by when i woke up at let's say
6 am by 605 i have the allergy medicine
claritin in my system 6 45 7 slowly
begin to start stop sneezing here with
you now at
1204 no i would have never known it was
no sign of allergies
four eye drops in each eye 24-hour
clarity and you this is something that
you do on the reg every day of my life
no i i do allergies i am a 12 month
i'm a 365 hour you're kidding me right
now 100 something what are you allergic
we're out there dander
uh dander is a fun word dandruff is a
fun word
um uh you know of course all the pollen
moss all that but yes dander uh cat hair
i was allergic to um fake plants for a
while but that went away um what hair uh
yeah i was yeah this was a weird thing i
had a fake plant allergy
most people have allergies to real
plants fakes real horticulture and cats
yeah so this is this isn't even seasonal
you live with this i take claritin 12
months a year did you check with your
doctor you could take a clarendon 365
days in a row i never bring it up to
them maybe maybe just i should
there's nothing there's nothing
more for you from the doctor than over
the counter i would say every day of my
life since i'm maybe 15 without miss
maybe a day or two here i've taken
clarity
is that great is that bad
i would certainly look it up
can you take clarendon for 20-plus can
you take allergy medicine for 20-plus
years
maybe that's why i can't dance yeah
claritin blocks the action of histamine
that steps in the body that initiates
allergic symptoms itching sneezing runny
nose and allergic skin rashes right but
what happens pimpy can you say what can
you take claritin okay to take claritin
every day for years
well
you could take claritin daily and long
term it's an antihistamine used to treat
for allergy symptoms if your symptoms
are year round then it is able to be
taken long term what there you go
yep
what are the long-term effects wow
oh my god this class of drug is
associated with psychological side
effects such as irritability and anxiety
hallucinations aggressive behavior
depression suicidal ideation or behavior
and insomnia
all that so you don't sneeze
it seems like a lot yeah but you gotta
understand clara and the people of
clarendon asking a lot when i when i
wake up though i mean swole like i'm
swollen i'm see here's here's here's
here's the typical knife you know you
you know you're sneezing you can't take
it you take clarity and then you want to
maybe kill yourself kill myself you
ready for what happened let me tell you
what let me tell you what a what a night
in may it's me because may is where it's
the worst i get it seasonal but may
gonna be mine it's gonna be may in in
new york city northeast may is the worst
for a lot of allergy april may is the
worst that's why i don't that's why
so you know how i'm always like oh i
don't like the heat because i associate
the heat with sneezing where when it
rains it washes away the pond my
allergies are almost non-existent when
it rains the day if it you're only happy
when it rains
you want to sit you want to know what
the worst days of my life are please
when it rains listen to me when it rains
okay so everything's there and then the
very next day is a sunny windy day
uh what dead what happens because it
washed off all the pollen and stuff from
the trees and i was just sitting there
now it's sunny and the wind is whipping
it off it's like an allergy tornado oh
so the water doesn't wash it away no it
just like knocks it around nope and
you're oh my god this is horrific let me
tell you what a night is for me in may
you know this is what happened this is i
would say let's say whatever there is
you learn to live with this half of may
this is what i do i go to sleep here's
how i sleep here's what i do i usually i
take a shower brush my teeth sometimes i
don't take a shower but i always brush
my teeth and i was a nighttime shower
guy a morning shower guy i go night time
i flip flop i like it at night too i've
noticed we've been on the road before
and you'll take you'll get off the plane
you take a shower that morning you will
get a plane hold a travel day you don't
shower before the show
you'll go right into the show because
you said i took a shower this morning
even though i went through three
different time zones yeah the time zones
don't really bother me i take a shower
in the morning sometimes i'll take a
shower when i get home from the show for
me i have to take a shower for every
time zone i cross okay so if i'm going
new york tell me i gotta take three
shots about it if you go to like india
how many times all that
you ready for this 12 time zones what do
we think pimp how many time zones are
there my guess is 12.
24 times
oh well i guess that makes sense 24
hours yeah i guess so but i didn't think
it was like that
24 time zones what's the furthest time
zone away from like so this time zones
there's times those in the middle of the
ocean that nobody cares about no
dude and also do you realize like like
new year's eve it's like bs because by
the time it's new year's day for us it's
been new year's day in australia
it been done i flew to australia on
november 5th landed on november 7th my
birthday is november 6.
so you lost you didn't celebrate it i
didn't i didn't have the day of the did
you go the 5th of the 7th when you
celebrated i celebrated after i got to
australia so the seventh yeah or that
week but i didn't feel that i didn't
feel the birthday day here we go the
last place on earth where any date
exists is on howland and baker island in
the idlw time zone the western
hemisphere side of the international
date line and so is the last spot in the
globe for any day to exist therefore the
day ends
when it ends
aoe
when it ends on howland island
interesting so where is howland island
anywhere on earth
end of day okay can you google where
howland and baker islands can you oh but
i do you were in the middle just so you
know we were in the middle of telling me
what uh what happened to me in may yes
so typically
wow look at how remote howland island is
and big oh it's in it's
it's actually not that far
oh it's it's by
actually howland island is closer to us
than australia's because they go you go
around the world
oh and the us owns it two uninhabited
what's in an atoll
yeah that says
howland island and baker island are two
atolls two [ __ ]
oh okay that's a question it's an atoll
oh wow it's a ring-shaped coral reef
dude some of the world is beautiful
okay so what i do let me tell you so
what i do
almost every night in may as i go to
sleep no shirt on shorts
i wake up
in the morning
usually butt naked why
i get so sneezy in the middle of the
night
tissues aren't enough i take off my
shorts and blow my nose into my shorts
i have no choice but to do that
[Music]
[Laughter]
what are you doing why don't you just
put tissues by the bed i go through too
many tissues
who are you gonna who puts up with this
you take you off your boxers and just
start blowing your nose into your boxes
at 3 30 in the morning i'm told just put
tissues by the bed do you do your
laundry
no and then what you're just blowing
your nose into your boxes and then where
did that where does that go
uh i put that in the wash and i wash
those and then i so when you see
you might see a pair of my shorts that
look like there's just jizz stains all
over it it's allergies allergies okay i
i've never heard of this in my life i'm
told i've been told many many many many
many times you don't want to get out of
bed okay i've been told many many times
by jasmine my girlfriend my mother my
children that
she's like if women knew
how disgusting you were yeah and and
what it really was like living with you
none of these girls would ever put heart
eyes on your instagram pics none of
these girls would ever tell you that
you're cute right none of this would
happen because you she said you are by
far the most disgusting human being yeah
i've ever been around in my life
and i'm like why don't you leave that
and she's like because you queue
[Laughter]
yo that is disgusting dude yeah like i
just a little bit of my opinion changed
of you just now a little bit and i
thought i knew you very very well well
here's the thing i mean you're taking
off your shorts and you're blowing your
nose into your shoulders
and then you just roll around with the
shorts and then you is is that then your
your tissue for the rest of the evening
and in the sleep
i'll what i'll do is i'll blow my nose
into my shorts and then when i wake up
in the morn and that usually puts me to
sleep because i have like a big tissue
there that i could just blow into it and
i'll blow it to all parts of the shorts
and then what i have and then what i'll
do is and by the way in the winter time
when these seasonal allergies once a
while they kick them in the winter i
blow those right into my pajama pants
yep um so i'll do that
and then and then i um
i when i wake up in the morning i'll
take those those shorts and i'll put
them in i'll put now let me be honest
with you we're just being honest here
yeah don't not be honest now if it's not
too bad if it's not if there wasn't too
much snot no come on bro i will put on i
will put on boxer shorts
i'll put them back on and go to the gym
with them
oh my god
oh my god
let me ask you a question
it takes effort to
take off your pants take over your
shorts and then start blowing you know
it's like does not it's not like that
crazy for you to get up real quick
and go like 10 feet to get a tissue well
the thing is is first of all a lot of
times i i'll forget to have tissues and
i'll have to blow my nose into paper
towels and that chafes my nose sure but
a nice pair of little lemon shorts don't
chafe
that is true they're probably five
percent rayon they are
you
okay okay but you live with this so why
haven't you ever said let me get some
puffs plus with aloe
or kleenex put by the bedside and i will
stop blasting my mucus into my own
undergarment well i i do i do but
there's a lot of i will go through on
high allergy season especially now my my
daughter my oldest daughter has
allergies too
we will go through a box of
puffs plus with aloe in about an hour
and a half we'll blow through it right
because they get i mean i'm talking
about it's non-stop niagara falls of
allergy snot coming out of my cabinet
and that's despite the claritin despite
the clarity no if i don't know if i know
clarendon dude if i had no claritin i
would be dead i'd be one of those guys
that drops dead of allergies and
claritin is your go-to choice claritin
is literally my savior okay claritin i
was taking claritin d but now i got high
blood pressure so they said i can't take
the d clarity congestion but the the
stuff the properties in the decongestant
raises your bp so i can't take clarity
but i don't really need claritin d okay
i i i oh that's right that's why when i
take nyquil they say it's bad day cool
and i called it oh good
so so yeah so that's but what i will say
what i will say is
i'm not doing it fully but there's a
cafe on staten island on bay street it's
called balloon cafe shout out bloom cafe
it's all vegan gluten-free dairy-free
place they have other options but not
free shout out free anything that's like
today i ate a gluten-free dairy free
devil dog i wanted to have a devil dog i
had to now now listen i know what three
dairy-free did it taste good it tastes
awesome
if you want gluten-free dairy-free stuff
they have vegan cheese vegan eggs all
that stuff it's so the bloom cafe on
staten island it's got so good is it a
vegan cafe
they have all vegan options but if you
want just a regular egg and cheese they
could do that for you okay they can do
that for you and it's all nut free
because i think one of the owners kids
it has a nut allergy so it's all nut
free plates so that you can't get almond
milk but they could get rice milk if you
have rice milk
rice milk rice milk is awesome shut up
different kinds of milks but what i will
say is since i've been eating a little
bit of these vegan products i know
people say oh just because it's vegan
doesn't mean it's not healthy right yeah
i know first of all shut up because it
does mean it's healthy stupid [ __ ]
yeah yeah i just literally ate a vegan
free i just ate a dairy flea gluten
gluten-free deviled dogs the same as
eating a salad it's the same thing i
believe so 100
so so i i
since i've noticed since i've been
taking like i don't drink as much milk i
don't drink as much i don't eat as much
processed foods because when i go to
this cafe it's not processed it's
less allergies
and less and dairy dairy mess because it
clogs up mess with no dairy in there
dairy clog shops
they say you can't have like milk when
you have a cold or something that's what
they say because it clogs you up what
does milk do to you that it clogs you up
when you have a cold i'll tell you what
it's not doing your body good it's not
it ain't doing your body good i don't
think i don't know if milk i think milk
had an ag campaign that made us think
that milk was better than milk is big
milk yeah is is a whole corporation
yeah dude they
what
bubba's in what world would a human
being a born human baby that that we saw
from look who's talking last week's
episode yeah a human baby why would i
need to drink cow's milk it's another
animal i gotta suck cow titties now
right why that's big milk because cows
were the cheapest animals to milk
so therefore let's make up a whole
campaign about calcium and blah blah
blah blah blah you don't need it
it's all lies there's rocket fuel in the
milk yeah that's true we saw that you
don't need that so we grew up on that
but then again like let's say you get a
little bit older what do you have in
your cereal with you can't do with titty
milk i do it almond milk do a rice milk
oh if i'm gonna have a magic spoon i do
an almond milk how long how long has
almond milk and rice milk been around
years really yeah the chinese invented
it years ago really
all it is is water and like almond
it's not like i don't know why i don't
think it yeah look drink was invented as
in the 12th century back in the 12th
13th century almond milk was consumed by
islamics and christians during fasting
season sorry islamics and christians
would islamics plus christians equals
chinese right
okay
so i have been using grove uh in the
house before they came on as a sponsor
for this podcast you've been using so
much grove i call you grover cleveland
that's that's what you call me babe call
me grover just go and call me late for
dinner that's what it is that's what it
is grove is basically a website that has
all these green uh better alternatives
for the household products that you use
in your house just a whole slew of them
did you know that only nine percent of
plastic actually gets recycled nine
percent that's mind-blowing no matter
how much we put in our recycling bin so
at grove collaborative they believe it's
time to ditch single-use plastic for
good and that's what i've been doing you
know i don't do bottle see that yeah not
in my house no i don't i don't do i
haven't done a plastic bottle in over a
decade yeah i'm an idiot i'm using too
much plastic
no there's no really growth so grove
carries hundreds of products aimed at
replacing single-use plastics across
your home and personal care routine by
2025 grow will be 100 plastic free that
soap on the counter there instead of
using liquid soap in the bottle it's
like a bar and you kind of just rub the
sponge on the bar it stays there and
you're eliminating that plastic we do it
even even even the products we have like
we use like uh for for washing dishes
and stuff it's a powder that we get and
it comes in the same we refill it in the
same plastic dude
literally the winner of the nobel peace
prize should be grove it should be two
million households already shopping
sustainably at grove if you go to
grove.com hey babe today you'll get a
free gift set worth up to 50 dollars
with your first order plus shipping is
fast and free get started right now at
grove.com hey babe that's grove.com
babe you know that i'm a serial lover
okay dude i know favorite food ravioli
peanut butter and jelly bowl of cereal
that's my that's my dream meals of the
day okay start off with cereal peanut
butter for lunch ravioli i don't care
that's what it is that's what it is and
i had to stop eating cereal the way i
did when i was a kid
and a lot of calories we talked about
this before but one of the reasons one
of the ways i get cereal back in my life
is magic spoon because magic spoon first
of all it's only 140 calories of serving
yes okay sugar and carbs slash and your
keto it's keto friendly it's gluten free
it's grain free soy free it's low carb
the only thing that it's not free of is
taste it's full of taste that's right
so good my favorite is the peanut butter
i i like that peanut butter magic spoon
is i i eat it with almond milk i love i
i can eat honestly a box of that one
peanut butter is good i like the fruity
the frosted i haven't tried the cocoa
yet there's also a blueberry look it's
there's zero sugars comes protein in
there 13 to 14 grams of protein oh the
cinnamon flavor the cinnamon is so good
yeah oh my god the cinnamon is so gotta
love it i mix the peanut butter and the
cinnamon sometimes you mix the cinnamon
you could do that and or you could order
your own you could order pre-packaged or
the ones you want from them the bundle
pack of four boxes it's only four net uh
net carbs each serving it's amazing this
is it we love it try it out go to
magicspoon.com hey babe to grab your
delicious cereal and try it today be
sure to use our promo code hey babe at
check out to save five dollars off the
order uh magic spoon is so confident in
their product this is a no-brainer it's
backed with a 100 happiness guarantee if
you don't like it for any reason refund
your money no questions asked boom boom
boom remember get your next delicious
bowl of guilt-free cyril at
magicspoon.com hey babe and use the code
hey babe to save five dollars off thank
you thank you magic spoon thank you so
much magic spoon i want to thank you
from the bottom of my magic spoon filled
heart yes for sponsoring this episode
milk and okay the problem with milk
maybe it's a sensory trick it's like
david copperfield milk and saliva in
your mouth create a somewhat thick
liquid
that can briefly coat i'll blow that
right into my shorts
that can briefly coat the mouth and
throat the sensation that lingus may be
mistaken
oh my god sounds good
if you start saying gross stuff or we
look at girl stuff i i will draw heave
instant without even so you can't even
read the the word phlegm is disgusting
it's so gross bro slim and you know what
else scott's word feet oh lemon feet
feet yeah yeah yeah yeah fleming i
literally i think i'd rather watch a
live beheading than listen to the words
phlegm and feet uh i'll listen to
flaming feet on that one but i will tell
you that i'd rather somebody [ __ ] in my
mouth than listen to the words fleming
feet yeah again i'll go with my feet
even though they're gross um one time on
the show what would you rather do listen
to the words flaming feet or wear my
booger shorts
[Laughter]
zoom in on his face
i can't think of look at this i can't
pick
i can't think of eating your boogers
i can't think of doing that
that's that's the hideous thing i told
you right yeah yeah
um
do you lay back in bed with the snot on
your pants no i'm butt naked
i put them on what i'll do is i'll get
naked i feel sneeze coming on i get
frustrated i pull my shorts off i get
butt naked now i'm butt naked i blow my
nose into my shorts and vinnie's next to
you she's right next to me i blow my
nose in the shorts and and then i put
the shorts on the floor and then as i'm
sneezing throughout the night i quickly
pick them up pull them into the shorts
and then put it down and
she's jasmine vinnie's woken up multiple
times in the morning
and being like chris you're [ __ ]
disgusting yeah i'm not picking those up
i'm not washing them and then i'll just
wait for the golden stairs and i'll put
them in the laundry now do you ever just
blow your nose in the sheets
that i've never done that'd be wildly
disrespectful
[Laughter]
yeah that's what i i've never blown my
nose of the sheets but it is a good idea
dude i can you know what's so funny i
blow my nose into my shorts and i've
jerked off into my socks so many times i
just love lighting up my clothes i've
never even done that never charge up
into yourself what did you talk about
when you were a kid i don't understand
why that's a thing i never understood it
well because it was just the easiest
thing to clean i mean you know i i just
never understood like i don't even get
how the two come together like like no
pun but like i don't i don't get like
like why is that even an option versus
any garment or just versus a paper towel
thing yeah i think because like you know
i'm not gonna do that to my clothes i
mean i would i literally there's been
many times where i've been playing like
you know i grew up playing basketball i
was playing basketball defending someone
with with [ __ ] riddled socks
don't socks get respect
socks don't get no respect do you think
socks is the thing that'll eventually be
like
we don't need that in the future no you
need socks no i'm saying like somebody
will make a shoe that's a sock like like
like because we're putting on it's too
many steps you got to put on a sock and
a shoe like already they're coming out
with shoe socks i saw that i bought them
years ago like oh i'll try this and
they're like they they stick they adhere
to the inside of your shoes and they're
like a sock lining so that shoe has like
a it's not like sock sock but it's like
so you don't need socks right and i i
never tried this what about like they
wanted me to cut it out and i'm like i'm
not gonna kiss what about like a
hologram sock i'm sure it's coming
holograms in general are coming like
holograms i think over the next 10 years
i agree but you know like when the ipod
came out our minds were blown and now
when you look at an ipod you're like oh
look remember how old that is but it's
like happened so quickly because now
it's iphones and well like iphones came
quick like
pods are gone right yeah 10 years ago
like to have pictures and videos on your
phone you'll be like what that's crazy
like yeah it wasn't as advanced but now
it is
i think holograms are going to come out
in a big big big way i think so as well
isn't aren't people investing in that
yeah um um there's a hologram company
right now that howie mandel owns that is
literally you can put a hologram like
you can book a speaker or a singer or a
comedian and then from
new york and have them in hong kong on a
hologram and they literally are
interacting like you could have we could
have a guest on via hologram right all
we would need is a is a piece is a box
as its biggest pimp's smallest camera
that would hologram them on here and
they're in a big machine back where they
are like a box and we are interacting
they're like and they're right here with
us they are on vr so when they look at
us they're here so when this calligram
looks at me they're turning and looking
at me in the camera you know how
sometimes it's hard for us to get our
schedules together we're both doing a
million things there's gonna be a time
actually we could probably already make
it happen if we wanted to invest in the
hologram machine where we could just if
you and i both just had access to the
hologram machines only pimp or somebody
would need to maybe not even pimp
somebody we need to be or just set up
the camera and we could do an entire
podcast without being there and i think
that
that is going to be the way of the
future i think that's just what it's
going to be most you actually don't even
need any of us there's a ai that creates
art so there's ais that can write your
jokes there's
computer technology that can just
somebody around my jokes but
dude that's the future it's coming
camera guys everyone's out robots are in
you know what we need to buy you
mentioned all right writing comedy oh
yeah they're programming it no you know
what we need to do you mention art
that's what all the all the money is at
all the billionaires they're investing
in art they're investing in in grain
metals like like hard objects grains
metals i don't know about gold but i
know grains and metals are big ones and
art they are buying so much art you mean
traditional art traditional art nfts
there's some type of so easy to hide and
laundry money yeah and it's and it's
just like it's all um
i don't know the word to describe it but
it's all like made up value it's like
sure you say it's 100 million inflated
inflated so right so i buy it now i'm
like well i've had it for 10 years now
it's 10 years old it's 200 million okay
200 million yeah but i don't know if
that's because i i spoke to my insurance
company about my sneakers
and like from what i bought them for and
then if they get stolen what they're
worth now what are you going with i
don't know whatever they are i don't
[ __ ] know great grey goose yeah so
and they said to me
that you'd have to
have that sale otherwise they had to go
by the receipts and i'm like well that
doesn't make any sense because they
appreciate like art
speakers so i bought a thousand dollar
pair of shoes that are now five thousand
dollars
right right so if that gets stolen from
me or destroyed in some way
you gotta give me the five
100 right and they're like well what did
you buy it for that's what we got to
give you i'm like no i have to educate
them that it appreciates like [ __ ] then
like well you got to show i guess you
got just so sales of that that item for
that amount of money
interesting
yeah no if you have any art no i gotta
get art i gotta get it
i gotta get it i gotta get art and i
gotta get watches yeah
yeah yeah i mean you could buy r for
investing you could buy it for you know
love the pieces there's different
reasons because i just started getting
into it a couple of years ago only i
started to say i want to make invest i
want to buy i want to find both i want
to find something that i really like but
that's also
good that's what a watch is if you don't
if you buy certain watches they
appreciate in value like insane yeah if
you as long as you don't put diamonds on
them or mess them up you can keep that
and then it just appreciates in value
but the art's tough because you're
investing in the lifestyle the i've been
friends with real famous artists and all
the ones you want to invest in you can
think they die any day
right isn't that kind of the game you
you invest in crazy artists that might
drop dead like like if you have a piece
of banksy if you have a piece of banksy
art right now you bought it for a
hundred grand and he drops dead tomorrow
and his name finally gets revealed
that's going to be worth a million bucks
immediately yeah but we don't know his
lifestyle you want an artist who's like
a drunk mess hmm that's why like picasso
and van gogh that yeah but if you had a
van gogh when van gogh was live it
wasn't worth dog [ __ ] no that's how
crazy that van gogh has no idea how
famous he was he is
he has no clue he died nobody knew who
the hell van but maybe that's why he's a
genius
maybe that's the way to do it
i tried to buy a picasso sketch and i
also tried to buy a basquiat uh sketch
and what happened with either one it was
a it was a bit a bit too much money
for what it was
uh i don't know what happens what do you
think what do you really think sal james
vulcan maybe it wasn't a picasso maybe
it was a little but it was a boss gap
but please continue what do you think
truthfully yeah truthfully
when you die what happens
you're gonna put me here now this is
what i go to therapy for every freaking
week
better help i know but yeah but you got
to put me up that's what the podcast is
sponsored by i'm afraid that nothing
happens
you
you're more afraid that nothing happens
yeah you so in other words if nothing
happened
you that would like if you went into
nothingness that would scare you more
than like going to hell
do you believe in heaven and hell no
that's man-made
yeah you believe your energy has to go
somewhere though
um
does it just dissipate
i don't know like i i feel like
i just feel like it might just be the
end might just be the end yeah well let
me tell you i want to feel spiritual i
want to think my energy goes somewhere
i want to think there's some type of
cognizance or something
something after but uh
odds are
i mean we don't have any
we don't have any uh proof of that after
all these years
right it's just hearsay your energy has
to go somewhere though you think so it
has to it's too much energy that your
vessel has to go somewhere i think
that's what your soul is stopping yeah
but i think that's what your soul is is
your energy continuing i think that's
what it is i think you this is like
so glow
girl just let it shine through
just to let your sun glow baby feeling
all so silky smooth wait a minute
wait a minute
let me tell you something right now let
me
sal i let me
show you something right now this is
gonna be good i watched a documentary on
netflix called the last breath have you
seen it
no
okay all right okay baby girl pimp you
seen this
it came out three years ago
talk to me
let me tell you i'm not going to tell
you the ending yeah but think about
just think about the fear okay
don't take that off because i want to i
want to i'm going to tell them about it
think about it put yourself in this
guy's shoes or tell me what you think
would happen are you ready for this yeah
documentary came out in 2019.
in the north atlantic ocean
in the middle of the north atlantic
ocean heard of it like the middle yeah
of the freezing cold north atlantic
ocean
there are groups of people yeah
that go down to the ocean floor okay
they go down to the ocean floor to what
to look for oil they're drilling for oil
there's companies that do it there's
mining companies that do it it's a whole
big thing
the only way
to make the initial drill to get the
equipment down no way dude
no way no way tell me someone's sacrif
wha you got it yeah you gotta okay you
have to a man or woman or transgender
has to go down there to the ocean floor
and start to drink dig the holes and do
the things themselves
let me tell you how it is so you're on a
boat at the top of the water like a
[ __ ] huge boat take a good look at
you because you're on a boat it drops
you you go into this little ball vessel
thing like it looks like a little
submarine or something submarine thing
you it's three guys two divers and one
guy watching the divers you have to stay
in that thing submerge underwater for 28
days
to acclimate your body i think to the
pressure of what it's going to feel like
down there
after those 28 days you then get
released down
you're tethered to the boat
the the little submarine thing is
tethered to the boat and then you're
tethered to the little submarine thing
okay the boat is anchored in the middle
of the rocky
freezing cold north atlantic water
you get down to the bottom of the ocean
floor thousands and thousands and
thousands of feet below the ocean
surface where not even sunlight can get
down the u.n complete
1000
which is what your fear is when you die
right
people have said people who have done
this job have said
there are sea monsters down there
there's fish that nobody's ever seen
they only described in sketches right
they even believe that there's they hear
noises down there it plays a trick on
you it is less explored than space we
know space right literally they know
more about space than they do about the
ocean floor because it is impossible
right to get down you have to be a
highly trained diver yeah to go down and
do this okay okay
so you're tethered to the boat which is
tethered to the other boat
one day shut up tethering shadow
tethering one day in i think it was 2011
there's a huge like perfect mark
wahlberg storm on the ocean yeah there's
two guys down there on the ocean floor
doing their thing the only lifeline you
have is the tether
back to the boat that you cannot even
see other than a little [ __ ]
flashlight you got on the front of your
space helmet you look like an astronaut
you're an underwater astronaut on the
front of your space helm you look like
it's it you know it's it's crazy you
gotta you got a flashlight who's the
character from south park
carmen you look like cartman your
cartman down there with a little
flashlight okay okay and then what you
do is you pull yourself up on the tether
i don't understand the reference of
southpaw but continue isn't he in a
spacesuit
cartman isn't carmen in a spacesuit in
an episode he's in a spacesuit who's the
south park character in the spacesuit
the orange outfit you talk about isn't
he an orange is it a spacesuit it's a
hoodie yeah okay yeah so take that part
out yeah um so so you're in like an
astronaut outfit down there the only way
that you can get only in the 26th season
continue the only way that you can get
back there is to pull yourself up on a
tether you you know in the water and
then you get back into that little boat
and then it takes you back up to the
other bigger boat
sometime in 2010 there's two guys down
there one guy gets back safely the other
guy the boat rocks so much it loses its
anchor snaps from the other boat the
tether snaps off the guy
on the thing he is on the ocean floor
tetherless alone on the ocean floor you
have 15 minutes of oxygen supply because
your oxygen is coming through the tether
if you ever get snapped off that tether
you have 15 minutes of oxygen supply the
boat is now getting swept away they have
no idea where he is they know he's alive
standing alone on the bottom of the
ocean
floor this sounds like one of the most
horrific things i've ever heard in my
entire life in complete
one thousand percent
darkness all he hears is crushing sounds
all he sees is potential sea monsters he
can see he can't even see his hand in
front of us
after three minutes his flashlight goes
out now he's literally standing on the
ocean floor in full 1 000
darkness
okay on the ocean floor he's going to
leave it all out there he's going to
leave it all out there who knows what he
does who knows when he dances and do you
want to know what happened
are you do you want me to tell the
ending
oh i want to watch this immediately do
you want to watch it you want me to tell
the ending ah
tell me what to do
i don't know like i was thinking about
when we when we were done today i'm
going to watch it
okay so i won't tell you no no just
tell me what to do how can we do this
how can we do well it's a spoiler so
it's a spoiler so if people are watching
and they don't want to see it then
should i want to see it or no i want to
see it now you i mean how do i not want
to see it so you don't want it so you
don't want to tell you to end or no
because it's wild what happens
all right will it ruin like will i still
watch the movie and my balls will be
blown off
despite you telling me the ending
do you think that i will be robbed of an
experience were you shouting the ending
out to me instead of experiencing it the
way that you experienced it
because this is a big this was this was
a big build to not to not pay off and
i'm i'm really you have my attention
xxx ten sension shout out success
intension um
i don't know what to do i don't know if
i if i tell you well i mean for the
viewer at least or the listener
i mean how much time do we have left in
the episode um a few more minutes okay a
few more minutes
i mean sounds so busy you know
[Laughter]
i'm surprised you want to hear it no
i've heard it on the other show okay all
right last breath okay okay let me talk
okay you know what
tell me and if you don't want to know
what it is now skip
three minutes okay
i forgot what his name is chris
something yeah so
the thing starts they're telling the
story they're showing pictures of him of
course you know he can't survive that
down there right because he's so far
down
and you have to regulate to come up yeah
so he's talking about you know his
wife's on you know talking about you
know
you know whatever like obviously you
know can't survive it right can i i
don't want to interrupt you because i do
want to hear this but you go down with
one tether
like one thing goes wrong you're
tetherless and that's where you find
yourself if there's how is it not a
backup to the backup to the backup plan
how is that sounds like you had shark
week yeah
yeah how do you not have eight tanks
down there with you or something like
that like what how do you does he have a
harpoon i think well i think they did
get sued by the national tether
association the nta yeah they sued them
yeah and so now things have changed
because of this incident things have
changed now the nta ain't going to
change the mta don't want to hear [ __ ]
if you're out if you work for the
national tethering association write it
hey babepod at gmail.com tell us about
what's so powerful of an organization no
matter what happens the mta is not going
to do anything about the tethering
so
talking about
you have yeah so when you get because
auctions come to the tether it's like
it's like you're in biblical umbilical
cord just same in build cord you saw and
look who's talking yeah so in the bib
yeah it's in the biblical chord as we've
read about in the ancient scriptures yes
yes so
so the the same in biblical court from
the old testament correct so
auctions coming through
tether
who the hell's calling me ortiz lisalot
ortiz i don't know
so so
you
getting oxygen from that tether rips off
you now have two little
[ __ ] oxygen canisters on each side
of your belt buckle like little spray
paint cans of oxygen okay what what do
you do like you know that you can't
survive it so you but you know you have
15 minutes that's a crazy thing to think
about right right you know you can't
survive but you know you have 15 minutes
left in the dark alone down there down
there do you just sit with your thoughts
well so what happened oh my god oh my
god so what happened is
you're down there with 15 minutes right
of oxygen the boat now has went so far
off the grid what they had to do they
did have his gps location on on his suit
so they knew where to recover his body
shout out garmin shout out carmen shout
out tom tom so what they did was they
had they had his gps suit on his they
had a gps location on his swimsuit
the boat
goes all the way
miles off course it's being just thrown
around in the ocean it they had to shut
the boat down they had to shut the boat
down and reboot it to get back on to get
all the electrical stuff back on to get
the paneling back on shut it down mike
shut it down
they send down you know i told you there
was that little machine that little
machine that they were in that little
bubble machine that they were in well
that was tethered to him that was
tethered to him so now the guy in the
machine because i told you there's one
guy
pulling
there's one guy watching both divers the
sec first diver gets back
the first diver in the tethering i mean
the machine gets he doesn't stay to help
no he they gotta
he doesn't even know he's like i'm back
where's the other guy
they're pulling up the tether it's a rip
tether no oxygen it's just
hissing because it's
because just auctioning like oh my god
so they send they send this boat thing
back down
because now the other two guys had to
get into like the actual ship somehow
like whatever
they send this machine down like you
know that thing in the titanic that like
what's it called jameson or you know
that thing that like looks for stuff you
know what i'm talking about
it's like a little robotic submarine you
know it's called drone what a drone
submersion it's not a drone it's like
it's got a name it's like winston or
something like that they have that kind
of thing oh yeah
so they go down
blindly they're like we need to recover
this man's body okay
45 minutes later 45 minutes later this
guy has oxygen for 15 minutes 45 minutes
later
they see him they see his body
his tether got stuck
to one of the oil rig machine it could
have been just floating into like a
black abyss right
they he somehow as luck would have it
you know it's really important for his
family he's tethered he's he's really
important for his family no to recover
the body oh of course of course
that was a discontinued thought i didn't
understand what you're saying his tether
yeah his tether is stuck
to the to one of these oil rig machines
so they see him so he didn't lose it is
he sucking air from the tether no they
see him
he's he's on to this oil rig machine
there they get him now the machine gets
him that same guy
that's pulling him up
you know that that was pulled up his
tetherless you know his body with the
snap tether now goes down and they see
him the machine gets him they start
pulling him up you know they've already
radioed that you know get paramedics
down here you know it's been half an
hour 45 minutes left they have the the
the
the the uh
things to pump his chest if they they
have anything they can but they're like
this but they also have a black bag it's
like this is a dead body
they pull him up they get him in they
take off his helmet
to put on the oxygen mask they took off
his helmet he goes what happened
he was alive no alive for 45 minutes
zero oxygen however
fully alive i have no
idea but what he did say was what he did
say was at the end of this all he was
alive this whole time he said he
remembers being in the blackness
being in the blackness of of the ocean
and then feeling the most sense of calm
he's ever felt in his life and he was
saying it's not that bad whatever death
is i must have met it it is not that bad
at all you just feel like you're as
tired because you know when you're so
tired when you just have to go to sleep
and when you're falling asleep it's the
most peaceful thing ever
that's what if you go peacefully if you
go peacefully but he wasn't peaceful two
minutes before that he was literally he
said he was thought he was gonna get
eaten alive by a monster he was going to
run out of oxygen he was like just
saying his goodbyes
somehow
alive for 35 to 40 minutes zero auction
he has no idea what happened
literally survives
go
alive like fully alive on the
documentary sits there's a scene where
it shows him sitting down
sitting down like the camera's coming in
and you just see him sit down and it's
him it's this guy chris being like i
survived it he survived it
literally this was in 2019 survived that
whole
ordeal whole amazing [ __ ] car dead of
covert this has been hey baby
no
[Laughter]
no
no
fully dead
no died dead no i can't tell if you're
joking dead he died
choked on a ham sandwich no how did he
die no i think he's still alive oh he's
actually the guest right here we got him
on a hologram say hello chris
[Laughter]
dude we are we did did you really hate
baby no no
uh yeah no right whatever you want to do
well well because then we could if it
would if it would have been if i would
have timed it a little bit better i
would have said i thought you were
building up to it i was
i was then his first words with this has
been hey babe
i should have said that instead of
saying i'm alive you should have said
this is haven yeah or whatever all right
but okay is that still worth watching
but how do they like what is their
explanation
how could we not have all heard of this
nobody knows at all nobody knows at all
how he survived nobody has any idea but
what what what was awesome is uh what
not even brain damage one week later he
got back in that tank and went right
back down to the ocean floor and has
done no less than a hundred more dives
since that incident
the last breath
unbelievable wow he wasn't even like
i'll never do that again i i survived i
i was playing with fire i was playing
with water i'll never do that again i'll
never do it again he went down there and
he said put me into the abyss put me
into the blackness you can't scare me no
no no it's not for me not for me not for
me i want to find out his address we'll
send him some merch yeah senator mccain
hey babe shirts and cane tanaka you
might not love kane
easily can outlive candy what is what is
what is in the genetic composition of a
person that can survive that and then
still want to do
it uh because you know i would give up i
would not do it again because i would
imagine you have a lawsuit on your hands
maybe not actually you probably signed
documents that you can't you you
probably can't because you say you want
to dive to the ocean floor you might die
what possesses the person to even want
to have that idea to do that to do it
and then to do it a hundred more times
after that experience harrowing yeah i
came out of karate kid in the theater
with my dad when it was out i crane
kicked the brick wall on the side of the
theater i [ __ ] up my toe so bad i've
never gotten to a crane kick formation
again 43 years later the exact same
thing as this guy from the last spot
like i won't crane kick again
you won't even crank kick i won't crank
again and this guy's
formation you never have never have it
because after 1988 or whatever way 86 i
never did it again you guys you'll do a
crane kick on the patreon
are we still recording no it's over
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey babe hey babe hey
baby